so this is just a general update from
daily mail it's not going to be world
war iii this is all a bluff democrats
and republicans ramp up demands to biden
to send polish migtone and fighter jets
to ukraine because putin is escalating
every day we also have estonia the first
nato country formally through parliament
calling for a no-fly zone over ukraine
every day we're inching closer and
closer to some reason the u.s or nato
has to be involved in this and now we're
getting these stories on march 11 abc
news reported that russia was moving in
with biochem suits
why would they say that because what
they don't just come out outright and
say yeah russia fired a biological
weapon they say remember last week when
we saw the russians wearing those
biosuits this is why
and now already nato uh some u.s
official has said it's effectively you
know a red line you know it's crossing
the line it's a red line for nato if
bladder vladimir putin uses chemical
weapons well biden said that last week
he said uh he was asked by reporters
when he gave his little speech on friday
i think it was friday
about what if putin uses biochemical
weapons and biden said there would be a
severe price but you also have the white
house saying
that a biochemical weapons attack from
russia would be
a false flag they also talk about that
already yeah they're talking about all
kinds of stuff it's very hard to
i mean i cover the news every day
we don't cover a lot of like what's
going on on the ground in ukraine at
post-millennial um
we're not foreign policy experts so we
don't cover that um we cover what's
going on in the u.s about it we cover
what's going on in canada about it but
like we're reading all of this stuff
every day we're trying to figure out
what's going on trying to understand it
and it gets more and more confusing all
the time it's like it's hard to know
what's going on we don't speak the
language it's very clear that you have
two sides there that are very well
versed in how to create propaganda wars
and they're doing it and we don't know
what's what it's all lies man but both
both parties every party to this whether
it's china whether it's russia the us
has a reason to lie
and it's just impossible to know what's
going on they they
you've got these people on twitter
you've got these people in media even
people on fox news you know our are
it feels like the the personalities on
fox news are trying to remain as close
to the populist american message of we
don't like war as possible while still
crop dusting vladimir putin is is
crossing that line and something needs
to be done but i think fox news knows
their audience would be like no war like
you know we're not going to play that
game
but fox news is one of the outlets that
keeps sort of talking about how there
should be a new no-fly zone no that's
that's what i mean it's like you know
what i was watching the five and i was
watching jesse waters and brett baer
jessie waters is like out there being
smug like hey we should have a no-fly
zone that's jessie me
yeah i don't like that
no for sure but but it does feel like
you know even greg gutfeld's you know
somewhat like i don't know what's going
on or what they're saying you turn on
like msnbc and rachel maddow is just
like do as the cult says oh i mean she's
not really on tv anymore but you get
that point i mean i discussed before we
came on that a guy on the bbc
uh stood and gave a piece to camera with
dead russian soldiers by his feet i mean
we're just in really nasty realms of
dehumanizing soldiers which i'm i'm
guessing didn't have much of a say in
whether or not russia
went into ukraine i don't i don't it's
remarkable to me how we keep hearing
this narrative that russia's losing
but then like when you actually look at
the details it's like a russian russia's
expanding you know like the media keeps
showing these small stories of victories
for ukraine
you know there's one video going viral
it's like russian convoy ambushed and
one tank gets hit and then you see all
those little stories but then the big
picture is
russia gains more ground russia takes
over a city i was in south korea a
couple years ago and um forgive me my
south korean family and friends uh i
went to this museum about a great south
korean general and it was it was funny
to me because it was like this was a
great naval leader who led some you know
korea because it was it was like you
know ancient time battles so it's all of
korea in in great war against japan or
something and i noticed something
interesting it was like in the first
battle a great you know 500 ships
confronted each other
and then it was like you go to the next
historical slide and it's like the great
general leading 50 ships against the 300
what a decisive victory and you go to
the next one and it's like his 12 ships
led a decisive victory against the you
know the 300 or whatever and i'm like
okay so so hold on
like you're omitting the nine out of ten
times he lost and only showing me the
one out of ten times he won
it's you know that that's kind of what
it feels like is happening here with
ukraine right they show all these little
victories but the bigger picture is
russia is slow rolling and moving in and
taking over but what's the what's the
aim with those lies is it too is it to
make putin really angry that we're
talking about him being a loser i think
demoralize the russian troops so that
they fight worse maybe but i don't think
they're watching this stuff i think it's
more so to convince the american people
that
we can and will win yeah that does that
and then when there's a chemical attack
they can be like oh no look guys you
know we're winning but we got to end it
now because of what russia just did and
then all of a sudden you know russia is
winning then all of a sudden nato comes
in and
flattens russia
i can't it just you think nato so you
think nato is going to just go in
what will they do
nato has 30 000 troops right now in
norway doing war games and 50 warships
moved into the region which is it's it's
the baltic sea it borders russia and
it's kind of like
is that a coincidence
you know they're they want to cancel
this this icbm test right to de-escalate
things but then send 30 000 troops for a
war game you know with 50 warships i
don't think they're up there for war
games i think they needed a reason to
send all those troops and get them ready
and just leave them there
yeah yeah because russia's been amassing
troops we know that right we know that
that's for a long time i was in a cab
actually recently with a friend of mine
um
and
the
it was an uber and the uber driver was
like really we were like hey how you
doing and he was like uh i actually just
got word today that i'm shipping out
what in a couple days i put in for my
retirement in august and now instead
they're shipping me to germany wow
yeah geez
to germany yeah interesting
i'm really curious what you guys think
of trevor noah coming out and saying
basically if trump were in charge this
would not be happening and he thinks
that biden probably wishes he could
bring trump in as president wild card
did he wait trevor noah said that yeah
he sure did it was pretty amazing we
covered that
yeah bill maher said something similar
yeah yeah yeah well trump said to i
think uh sean hannity the other night
that he said something to putin that
made putin clear that he should not
invade ukraine it was probably something
like i'm a crazy man and i might just
nokia he said he would nuke moscow right
so this is the craziest thing because i
think it's insane and i it's one of the
things that worries me about trump but
if it works i guess the official
reporting was that new york post ran a
story saying trump reportedly told she
and putin he told putin if you go into
ukraine i will hit moscow he told she if
you go to taiwan i will hit beijing
right and both leaders were like shocked
but hold on trump then came out and
bragged i told him i would nuke moscow
and he knew i meant it and i'm like he's
like he believed it maybe like five
percent but that's all you need is that
what he said
the thing too though is like the the
benefit of having trump as president
like uh he was essentially an anti-war
president the benefit of having him as
president was that he was so
unpredictable and crazy that no one knew
what he was going to do he was like the
homeless guy on a corner with a knife
and crazy crap guys
you know so america was like this crazy
unpredictable
nation with nukes run by well no it's
like someone handed them an ar right
in one hand and the pin is over here i
think he was a predictable man
he was a predictable blood shouldered
kind of bullish bloke i think you knew
exactly what he was going to do
what a crazy thing well i think i think
he'd i think he'd
out well i can't i'm trying not to swear
he'd um
if it was a urinating contest
he would always be the
the guy to win yeah so i think that's
correct i i think americans should have
felt safer in his hands than ever in
biden i felt safer with a crazy man at
the helm than somebody who's imminently
reasonable well a crazy guy that works
he kind of created like a crazy persona
but and it worked in cases like with
putin thought he maybe he would hit
moscow with a nuke but the american
people believed it they bought into it
as well so they thought he was crazy
half of them thought he was really crazy
i feel like turned out he was one of the
more stable presidents militarily i feel
like trump was the kind of guy to where
you could you could brag about doing
something that's kind of like
amoral or well he did no no no not trump
i'm saying if you said something like
trump could never beat me in a pissing
contest trump would be like when i take
a leak i spray it so far
so far so far everybody knows it
everybody knows i can i can write my
name in cursive like
i throw a ball faster than trump
no i throw the best balls the furthest
balls i throw them i throw my balls no
but only no no but only weird things
like if if you said you know i'm a pro
bowler and i could beat trump at bowling
he'd probably be like well he's a great
bowler he's very good everyone respects
him but it was like it was weird things
he would lie about where you're like why
is he so adamant about like
that being the thing that's a reliable
that's a reliable guy right because you
know that he's gonna say
you know that he's gonna say that when
when people challenge him so someone
like putin or china when they're sort of
coming up and saying no we're gonna
we're gonna be the world superpower he's
like no way i'm the super his super
power there ever
never walk the earth that five percent
thing is actually a really great point
because everybody knows that joe biden's
got a zero percent chance of launching
any nukes or taking any hard military
it's not gonna do a thing and everybody
probably says you know even putin and
she would be like trump probably won't
do it and then their advisors go
probably
and it's like
they're like bind's asleep he's never
going to do anything well but he's not
even away
no he's a useless daughtering old man
he'll he'll you know he'll he'll yell
come on man to putin right come on man
and then maybe he'll whisper and like
sniff some little girl's hair yeah
he could yeah he's reliable and sniffing
he's great at that so we have we have
chicken city which is our new live
stream where it's just the chickens
doing their thing and you know chickens
are animals so they do animal behaviors
but people calling whatever you know
roberto the rooster is getting feisty
people saying you know roberto giving
the old biden sniff to the girl
a good old biden sniff and i'm like
that's that's one way to put it it knows
better it's funny because
it's a rather family-friendly show it's
just chickens and we make jokes and i
threw blueberries to them and stuff like
that but the comments are hilarious when
people like make jokes about chickens
and whenever you're gonna be eating
people on our social media
they fight for it oh i thought they
didn't those the young ones they don't
even know the little ones were confused
they were like they didn't like the
blueberries one of the people on our
social media team beth base she's a
reporter of ours she was in um ottawa
covering the the truckers and everything
she's terrific every time biden does a
sniffy thing she's like i'm getting this
clip just wait he's sniffing people
again he's sniffing the girls again it's
wonderful
this is our reporter john
his beat is bite and sniffing little
girls yeah and he's like yeah basically
i just watch all of his presentations
and i just pull the clips of him
sniffing women is he getting nutrition
from people when he does that because i
know when you smell something you get
particles of the thing go into your
grosser body grosser
like when the bathroom is thinking biden
can't help it he's he's he sustains
himself i require nutrients yeah he's a
he's a smelly smell taste i have to
smell them
you need some energy
yeah he smells
he latches on and all right i mean
that's gross because a good smell will
wake you up and that's really gross if
that's what he's doing thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 p.m and if
you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there is a massive library
to check out so again go to timcast.com
or tune in monday through friday at 8pm
and we'll see you all there
you